Many people buy organic food hoping to feel
healthier, and potentially have a positive
impact on the environment. But are organic
foods even better for you and the environment
in the first place?
For plants, the term organic basically means
something grown without the use of synthetic
fertilizers or pesticides, but this is a little
bit misleading. You see, many consumers buy
organic to avoid pesticides all together,
but the truth is, organic farmers can still
use pesticides and fungicides to prevent insects
from destroying their crops, they just can’t
be synthetically made. There are over 20 chemicals
approved for organic use in the US derived
from natural sources like plants, but studies
have shown that some natural pesticides are
actually a more serious health and environmental
risk than man-made ones. Not to say they are
all bad, but simply that, ‘natural’ doesn’t
always mean better for you or the environment.
On top of this, not all organic foods are
completely organic. If a label simply says
‘organic’ it only has to contain 95% organic
ingredients. The label “made with organic
ingredients” on items like bread may only
contain 70%, while “containing organic ingredients”
may only have 50%. Only when a label says
“100% Organic” does it contain purely
organic ingredients. For what it’s worth,
the term “free range” also only requires
evidence of access to the outdoors for a minimum
of 5 minutes per day. Huh!
Interestingly, a meta-analysis conducted in
2012 found that organic crop yields are 25%
lower on average than conventional ones, though
differences vary greatly between types of
crops. For example, organic vegetable yields
are typically 33% lower than conventional
ones, putting a greater strain on the natural
environment as more farmland is required.
However, organic legume yields are only 5%
lower, as they are more efficient at absorbing
nitrogen from organic fertilizers. Of course,
many organic farming practices like crop rotations
and mixed planting as opposed to using mono-cultures
are better for the soil and the environment.
But are they better for you? After analyzing
237 studies, researchers concluded that organic
fruit and veggies are no more nutritious than
conventionally grown food. However, long-term
studies of purely-organic diets are difficult,
as most people eat a mixture of foods with
non-organic ingredients.
Those on short-term organic diets do show
higher levels of carotenoids, polyphenols,
Vitamin C and E, LDL cholesterol, antioxidant
activity, immune system markers, and ever
higher semen quality. But, the differences
are clinically insignificant. Children placed
on organic diets for ten days have lower levels
of organophosphates in their urine, which
in higher concentrations are associated with
neurological problems, but both levels are
orders of magnitude lower than the amount
needed to cause clinical harm. And just because
something is organic, doesn’t make it better.
An bag of organic chips, for example, is still
just deep fried carbohydrates with very little
nutritional value.
Most surprising is that organic food has a
higher incidence of being dangerous. Though
organic foods accounts for only 1% of agricultural
acreage or space, they account for 7% of recalled
food units in 2015. For example, this year
several flavours of Clif Bars were recalled
from stores due to organic sunflower kernels
that were potentially contaminated with listeria
- a bacterium which kills hundreds in the
US each year. Another study found E.coli in
10% of organic produce, compared to 2% in
conventional ones.
The truth is, eating organic foods can be
good for you, and in some ways be better for
the environment, but it’s not the be all
and end all. Production methods vary greatly
for both organic and conventional foods, from
one farm to another - or from local farms
to factory farms - and it’s likely a combination
of methods that will lead to the greatest
results for your health and the environment.
Organic and conventional foods can co-exist
and don’t have to be at odds with one another
- anyone who tells you with 100% certainty
one way is fully better than the other is
ignoring the science.
When it comes to your own health, it’s really
a combination of diet, exercise, various other
lifestyle choices, and of course, your genetics!